l'objet avis d'éviction pour fusion des
deux logements on se doutait que c'était
une fausse raison nous l'appellerons
michel son propriétaire a tenté de
l'évincer sous de faux prétextes et a
été débouté par le tribunal
administratif du logement malgré qu'il
ait eu gain de cause
michel craint des représailles et
prévoit quitter son logement à l'été
l'on sait comme garrocher sur les sites
de pour s'acheter des maisons pour
essayer de trouver des maisons
abordables mais il va devoir quitter le
quartier où il a grandi
maintenant c'est rendu un luxe au fond
de pouvoir choisir le quartier où on
veut vivre
michel n'est pas le seul dans cette
situation les évictions de logements au
doublé en 2020 la corporation des
propriétaires défend fermement les
demandes légitimes de ses membres aux
prises avec des coûts d'exploitation qui
explose quand on parle de frais de
gestion de réparation ou de rénovation
un majeur les coûts d'assurance
également ça devient impossible de
maintenir rentables surtout des petits
immeubles locatifs pour maxim roy à
l'art du regroupement des comités
logement et associations de locataires
du québec
cet argument ne tient tout simplement
pas la route quand on fait des travaux
on a des déductions fiscales qui
viennent avec ça on a plus de dépenses
donc mon impôt finale de l'année mais
l'immeuble prend de la valeur
et c'est là qu'on veut refaire notre
argent selon lui la création d'un
registre des loyers la seule façon de
freiner la spéculation immobilière et la
hausse des loyers
la corpiq elle n'est pas d'accord si
rien n'est fait on se dirige directement
dans le mur de toronto et vancouver
il faut notamment instaurer un contrôle
obligatoire des loyers ce qu'ils veulent
c'est un contrôle absolu des lois qui le
régissent n'est qu'un moyen d'arriver à
ce contrôle absolu pour andré fontes et
six as de québec solidaire
la solution à court terme en ces temps
de pandémie réside dans l'instauration
d'un moratoire sur les évictions peu
importe la raison les résultats elles
mêmes leur ce n'est pas le temps d'avoir
des familles à la rue en ce moment la
ministre des affaires municipales et de
l'habitation andré la forêt n'a toujours
pas répondu aux appels de québec
solidaire ici louis de belleval radio
canada montréal